good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight a lot of unprecedented
things happening but honestly not all of
them are shocking
for example it probably shouldn't
surprise you that once they got their
hands on
real power the same lunatics who don't
believe in human biology
immediately made a serious mess of our
economy
it took them less than six months to do
it first they acted like the us
dollar had no value they spent money
like they just printed it for the
occasion which needless to say they had
and predictably we wound up with
frightening levels of inflation which
for the record they still deny exists
but inflation does exist as you know
well if you live here
corn prices to name just one example of
a staple commodity that is now out of
control
have risen by 50 percent just since
january
but that wasn't bad enough the lunatics
then decided to make it even worse than
that
so they paid millions of americans more
than they make it work
just to stay home and do nothing to
justify doing this they used the word
kovid quite a bit
but it had nothing to do with the
pandemic they just wanted to break the
system and so they did
and the rest of us immediately wound up
with a bewildering combination of
rising unemployment in the middle of a
severe labor
shortage so at the very same time we
found ourselves with too many workers
and also
too few workers that doesn't even make
sense
but thanks to their policies that's now
exactly what we have
and then finally in case 2021 didn't
remind you enough of a grimmer version
of the 1970s
we now have serious gas shortages in a
country that was recently energy
independent
all along the east coast of the country
today people couldn't fill up their cars
take a look at the footage it looks like
venezuela
gas shortages now being reported in at
least six states and
expected to grow stretching down the
highways as
customers wait at the pumps the governor
of north carolina has declared a state
of emergency
this station there running out of fuel
as pumps run dry and officials urge
drivers not to panic by
we are completely out of diesel and gas
but already
long lines and low fuel gauges the
shutdown of the pipeline is also putting
major airports in baltimore charlotte
and others on the east coast at risk of
low supply
an emergency no if they ran out of weed
that would be an emergency
don't worry says the new york times none
of this is real
it's a conspiracy theory your eyes are
lying to you you're hysterical
in a piece today the new york times
reported that quote
since the pipeline shut down there have
been no long lines
at gas stations then apparently someone
in the new york times newsroom found a
working television
and the paper deleted that line from the
article a few hours later
without ever acknowledging it had
included the line in the first place
that was the paper but for their readers
on social media who presumably will
believe
absolutely anything the new york times
did not even bother to change the lie
that tweet is still up quote
since the shutdown there have been no
long lines or major price hikes for
gasoline
right not at all except in the state of
georgia where as of 3 pm this afternoon
almost 6 percent of all gas stations had
no gasoline
in virginia that number was almost 8
percent of all gas stations
in north carolina it was eight and a
half percent in metro atlanta
the biggest city in the south more than
20 percent of all gas stations more than
a fifth
had no gasoline to sell that is an
energy crisis
why is it happening well the official
explanation is that some mysterious gang
of cyber criminals hacked the software
at a major american fuel supplier called
colonial pipeline
colonial pipeline handles more than 2
million barrels a day
that's roughly half the east coast's
entire supply of diesel
gasoline and jet fuel and that's not a
small
problem in a country like every country
on earth
that still relies almost entirely on
fossil fuels to survive
but don't worry says her new energy
secretary jennifer granholm formerly the
incompetent governor of michigan quote
it's not that we have a gasoline
shortage
it's that we have the supply crunch oh
it's a supply crunch and that's very
different from a shortage at least in
some theoretical way that's important to
jennifer granholm
so what is the white house doing about
this supply crunch that is not a
shortage
well here's the answer from ann
newberger who is the confirmed
non-genius who somehow serves as the
deputy national security advisor
for cyber and emerging technologies so
first we recognize that victims of cyber
attacks often face a very difficult
situation
and they have to just balance often the
cost benefit when they have no choice
with regard to paying a ransom
colonial is a private company and will
defer information regarding
their decision on paying a ransom to
them did you
the administration offer any advice on
whether or not to pay a ransom
so typically that is a private sector
decision and the administration has not
offered
further advice at this time given the
rise in ransomware
that is one area we're definitely
looking at now to say what should be
the government's approach to ransomware
actors and to ransoms overall
that's the person protecting you from
the cyber criminals
colonial pipeline and new burger would
like to remind you is a quote
private company and as a matter of
principle the white house does not get
involved in the affairs of private
companies not unless private companies
were to use the wrong pronoun in a
sentence
in which case the fbi would arrive with
a swat team and make televised arrests
but in cases where the mere fuel supply
of the entire eastern seaboard is at
stake
and newberger and her friends at the
white house strongly prefer a hands-off
approach they're situationally
libertarian that way
what is this about well you know on some
level let's be honest about it the white
house
approves of this disaster yes some gas
stations are closed tonight
but soon enough the lunatics plan to
close all of them
close every gas station in the entire
united states shuttered forever
to make way for some new as yet not
quite defined means of transportation
that will magically replace the gasoline
engines
that we have used for more than 100
years this is a green revolution so who
cares about some old pipeline
remember that on his first day in office
joe biden shut down a pipeline that's
the first thing he did
it was the massive keystone xl pipeline
joe biden didn't wait for mysterious
hackers to shut it down he shut it down
himself
and more than 11 000 people lost their
jobs
and by the way gas prices went up in
case you haven't noticed gas prices have
never gone down
in the state of california the average
price of a gallon of gasoline is over
four bucks a year ago it was 270.
in illinois gas is three dollars and 20
cents a gallon last year it was 210.
it's not just two big liberal states
it's the entire country
in texas gas prices are averaging two
dollars and seventy cents a gallon
last year it was a dollar fifty in the
state of maine the average price of gas
is almost three dollars
a year ago was under two and so on
nationally americans are paying about 45
billion dollars more for gasoline
overall than they were last year
why this is the result of policy
decisions
made by the new administration this is
the green new deal
we've got it already and if you love gas
shortages
and electricity blackouts no air
conditioning 80 plywood
this is the program for you tomorrow the
administration's bureau of labor
statistics will release the new
official numbers on inflation in america
you should know that a key part of that
statistic is called the consumer price
index the consumer price index measures
the prices of a
carefully curated selection of goods and
services
and if tomorrow's consumer price index
number is flat rest assured the people
on tv will tell you it is proof
that inflation isn't real should you
believe them
well before you take their word take
note of what
is not included in the official consumer
price index
lumber for example because no one in
america buys building materials
so you should definitely ignore this
in a recent study by fortune.com the
average price of lumber is now
280 percent higher than what it was
pre-pandemic which is causing the cost
of construction to also increase
30 to 40 percent in a statement from the
division president for homes by
town jeff pemstein he says for a typical
fifteen hundred square foot home
just rough lumber used for framing has
increased from fourteen thousand dollars
per home
to twenty nine thousand
two hundred and eighty percent up wow
marge that's a lot what's going on here
well typically in the material world
where the laws of nature apply
when the price of something jumps that
quickly and that high
you've got a supply problem because it's
supply and demand there's isn't enough
of that
thing to go around more people want it
and we don't have enough of it
does that apply to lumber are there
fewer spruce trees out there than there
were a year ago
are those trees growing more slowly than
they once did have we seen a
280 percent increase in new houses being
built
the answer is no no and no the real
answer as you may have guessed
is that bad federal policies are
distorting the price of
everything in this country from two by
fours to diesel fuel
to corn dogs none of this is an accident
just as it wasn't
an accident when the power went out in
texas over the winter it wasn't a cold
snap that did it
it was a federal policy that encouraged
the state to rely on windmills which
don't actually
work so it's not a natural cycle
somebody did this to us on purpose
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else